- [Ben] Okay, fourth rule for debating:
Frame the debate properly.
So, you see this all the time.
People frame the debate
completely incorrectly.
So in every debate the left
is trying to frame the debate
in a particular way.
So let's take an example from
the last couple of weeks.
The left was trying to frame this issue
on the border as Donald
Trump is separating children
from their parents.
The Trump administration
responded by saying
"Well the reason we're separating children
from their parents is
because it was a deterrent."
That was the original response.
That is the worst response ever.
That is a bad response.
The way that they should
have responded is by saying
first of all that's
not true, we don't want
to separate children from their parents.
The Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals rules that
if we arrest people,
we have to separate
children from their parents
so if you don't like
that rule, we can go back
to the Obama era rule where
we detained everybody.
Which is of course what
Trump is doing now.
Right now Trump has said
"Okay, well fine we'll detain everybody."
Then the left goes "Well it's nazi-esque
when you separate parents and children
and it's nazi-esque when
you keep them together,
because their end argument is
they just want everybody released.
But how you frame the debate
originally really matters
in a major way.
Now President Trump actually
is typically very good
at framing the debate.
President Trump actually
is great at picking
a frame that works for
him and then moving on it
so instinctively he has
a good feel for this.
So on the immigration debate
when he says immediately,
"Democrats want open borders."
That is a good way to frame the debate
because that is actually the debate,
and Democrats don't
want to have that debate
because they lose that debate.
They want to have the
you're mean to kids debate.
The problem with this
latest roll-out is that
if they'd rolled it out with
you want open borders, we
don't want open borders,
the reasons parents are
being separated from kids
is because that is the current law,
we'd like the law to change and we're
calling on Congress to do so.
That would have been the way
to frame the debate totally.
They're coming around to it,
it's just a little bit late.
So it's all about framing the debate.
Whenever you're debating anybody,
and this is true for any topic,
the left has a series
of frames on the debate.
Whenever they talk about
global warming for example,
they'll frame the debate as
you don't care whether
there's global warming,
or you are a global warming denier.
The way you should actually
frame the debate is
okay what are your
solutions to global warming?
The reason being that, I
assume there are very few
climate scientists in the room.
I'm not a climate scientist.
I don't know that much about
the reactivity of the
atmosphere to carbon emissions,
but even if I accept the IPCC estimate
that by the end of the century,
the average climate across
planet Earth will rise
something on the order of
seven degrees Fahrenheit,
that does not suggest that
massive government interventionism
is necessarily the fix.
In fact, it's a pretty good
chance that it's not the fix,
considering that if the Kyoto
Protocols or the Paris Accords
were implemented right now,
it would barely lower
the temperature at all
according to their own best estimate.
Once you get into that, the
left has nothing to say.
They'd prefer to stick in the
area where you're an ignoramus
who doesn't know anything about science
and you hate science.
So it's all about reframing
every debate, right?
On abortion it's about not
arguing about women's choice
it's about arguing whether
this is a human life or not
because that really is the
only debate that matters.
Alright, I'm not against women's choice,
women can choose to do whatever they want
just they can't kill babies
because I can't kill babies,
because no one can kill babies.
So, it's all about where you
choose to frame the debate.